The Joe Rogan Experience are you a big
ghost guy
um I believe it's possible I'm obsessed
are you I I so really weird side hobby
of mine I go ghost hunting I've been
like around the world yeah it's
incredible what have you experienced
have you ever had like an absolute
moment where you're like oh my God I'm
in the presence of a poltergeist not
still not a thousand percent I've
definitely witnessed things that I
cannot for the life of me explain that
have creeped me out the timing has been
impeccable I've seen things move that
there's just no [__] way that they've
moved I've gotten answers back on EVPs
but for me it is one of those things I
do need to see it isn't the EVP like a
radio though no EVP is just a recorder
it's a record what is um what's that
radio thing I'm sorry then what is the
one where they where they like listen
there's a bunch of different names my
daughters heavily into this [__] what
does she watch I have like Sam and Colby
you had them on right yes so right guys
so
I met these other guys there's another
Channel called the overnight Channel who
are equally as popular as Sam and Colby
and they actually used to work together
then I believe they spit off into each
do their own thing but that's who I
started going with so I'm I'm very
familiar with those guys so these kids
they uh the Sam and Colby guys just went
into The Conjuring house I was just
there maybe a month and a half you went
to The Conjuring house by myself Joe
okay do you believe that there's
something going on in that house
The Conjuring movies are [__] great
it's my favorite franchise they're fun
and there's so many of them they really
did it right like if you want to be
smart they branched off with the nun
they branched off with the Annabelle and
I love the way they tie in the stores
that each one to make it all one
chronological story it's genius yeah I
I will say I wasn't
I wasn't as scared as I've been in a lot
of places we've been there is some kind
of Solace to the house but you get to
know the history of it and it just it
does make sense that there'd be
something here I mean it's on some Ley
lines of water underground it's there
was war spot there there's apparently
bodies buried on on the property in the
walls of of the um the property
structures and stuff
there's a lot of history that goes into
it that just makes for the kind of The
Perfect Storm for some creepy [__] but I
didn't witness anything that was that
insane some items move some some cars
rolled off of the children's dressers a
couple of times on cue and that's that's
the one thing I do pride ourselves in
these videos is so often we get
absolutely nothing because we don't fake
anything
so you only get to see the highlights
like there's so many times we'll go to a
place that is so notoriously haunted and
we'll be there for 10 hours and get
absolutely nothing and it sucks but that
makes when something does happen that
much more valuable it's so much more
impressive what do you think so do you
think a ghost is like a us the soul of a
person that's left behind or do you
think the ghost is almost like space and
time because of a horrible incident
contain a memory
and like that memory is almost like it
it like shows up in current time
sometimes there's a guy named Rupert
sheldrake I forget what his uh field of
study is but he had this theory about uh
things and he he believes that objects
contain memories oh interesting it's not
he's not the only one inanimate objects
yeah that things contain memories and
this is one of the reasons why like
people kind of universally support this
idea that if someone was murdered in a
house you must tell the people inform
the people that are about to buy it you
have to tell them hey somebody got
murdered in this house like maybe you
don't maybe you don't want to buy this
house now does the maybe you should
think about it does the potential owner
have to ask that information it's a good
question
um I'd want to know yeah I think it's a
good question I think they should have
to inform you because there's something
about someone being murdered in a spot
that freaks us out and this this is my
question how you knew the conjured house
was haunted right so you go there with
this feeling and this expectation that's
what I always wonder about these things
like how much of how much of and it this
isn't just imagining things this is like
the Mind itself seems to have
some unmeasured effect on the world yeah
I I think the way you think has an
unmeasured effect in terms of like this
there's energy that you put out there's
connections you make with people they're
very very unmeasured and you don't
manifest your own perception of things
for sure yeah so what my concern is is
like if you go into a place with a
pre-existing knowledge of ghosts like
you think ghosts are here you think
ghosts are real you have this thought in
your mind that you you maybe experience
a ghost in this place that's haunted
you're at this elevated level of
anticipation you're probably really
nervous and kind of freaked out and your
imagination starts firing up and I'm not
even saying that these people are lying
or that they're seeing things that
aren't there I'm saying maybe you make
things show up maybe you see memories
maybe you experience some horrible
energy that existed in this spot 50
years ago 100 years ago that there's
like ways you can tune into that I could
see that being possible but to me that's
what's so exciting about it is like you
go hoping for those solidified answers
you're you're going hoping to witness
something that you couldn't have
possibly made up but you know why I
think that too is like you never see him
in the daytime ghosts don't exist on
this sometimes yeah but not outside
they're never outside very good point
that's my point is like you're always
trapped so you're always in this like
weird space like if you had a wolf in
your house you'd be freaked out you'd
want to get outside yeah right you don't
want a wolf in the fire oh it's a
[__] wolf in the house yeah anytime
you're in a contained area your brain
has this heightened sense of like being
trapped in Awareness yeah and how to
escape I mean every horror movie is the
same when you've got to get to the door
get to the door right everybody's trying
to Fumble with the keys the monsters
chasing them and they get it just in
time right that is a reoccurring theme
in the human mind if you're you're
trapped in a [__] house with a killer
or a ghost or a wolf it's scary you know
where that makes the most sense we did
the USS Hornet up in the Bay Area yeah
and we had the whole ship to ourselves
which I was so excited about because I
love military stuff I love history I was
so excited to go there and just witness
it and they sent me by myself on a
basically a game of hide and seek where
they had to go find them in the ship
somewhere after I had to like count to
100 by myself
it was the most terrifying place I've
ever been because if you've never been
in like the bowel of a ship it's so
unfamiliar like doorways don't look the
same you know you have to step over them
and everything there's so many pipes and
everything sticking out it's such an
unfamiliar environment especially in the
dark it's terrifying you think I can't
possibly run away from something in here
it's too there's too many obstacles you
don't you don't know if that's a wall or
a pipe or something peeking around to
like look at you it's [__] terrifying
because of exactly that you feel so
trapped